الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه تقييمك في
التركيز في الاونه الاخيره على مزيد من
تسليح اطراف الحرب كيف يمكن الحد من هذا
خاصه انه الحرب بدات فعلا تتخذ منحه وجودي
والحديث عن الجلوس الاطراف على طاوله
مفاوضات يبدو انه لا يوجد صدى عند الاطراف
بلا شك اوكرانيا لديها كل الحاق في الوجود
وهذه الحرب شنها الجانب الروسي
وهذا اعتداء الصارخ ضد الدوله مستقله
بلا شك تسببت هذه مشاكل جمه خاصه على
النظام الدولي
عايزين
اعتقد بان هذه الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي بشكلين
اذا
خرج المعتدي الروسي من اوكرانيا
خلف هذه الحرب الروسيه انا اعرف الرئيس
بوتين
وعبر هذا البرنامج او انه اطالب الرئيس
بوتين بوضع حد لهذه الحرب وتحرير كافه
المناطق الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
والسحب قواته من اوكرانيا فاذا ما فعل ذلك
فهذه الحرب ستنتهي فورا اما
اذا لم يحصل ذلك فعل الانسانيه جمع ان
تدعم اوكرانيا في حربها من اجل بلادها
وكذلك لحقهم في الوجود
الامر الى مسائله ومحاسبه كافه الاشخاص
المسؤولين عن هذه الحرب وهذه الحرب
بالتاكيد لا يجب ان تصل الى المستوى
النووي او تمضيه هذا الاتجاه ولا يجب ان
يكون هنالك تصعيد والكل في العالم
يريد ان
جرى حلا سلميا في اسرع وقته وانا من بين
هؤلاء ونحن نحاول الانخراط مع كافه
الاطراف ونحث الجميع
الابتعاد على العنف والبدء بالمفاوضات
والحديث في اسرع وقت